My name is Erik Demaine.
You should call me Erik.
Welcome back to 6.046.
This is Lecture 2.
And today we are going to
essentially fill in some of the
more mathematical underpinnings
of Lecture 1.
So, Lecture 1,
we just sort of barely got our
feet wet with some analysis of
algorithms, insertion sort and
mergesort.
And we needed a couple of
tools.
We had this big idea of
asymptotics and forgetting about
constants, just looking at the
lead term.
And so, today,
we're going to develop
asymptotic notation so that we
know that mathematically.
And we also ended up with a
recurrence with mergesort,
the running time of mergesort,
so we need to see how to solve
recurrences.
And we will do those two things
today.
Question?
Yes, I will speak louder.
Thanks.
Good.
Even though I have a
microphone, I am not amplified.
OK, so let's start with
asymptotic notation.
We have seen some basic
I am sure you have seen it in
other classes before,
things like big O-notation.
And today we are going to
really define this rigorously so
we know what is true and what is
not, what is valid and what is
not.
We are going to define,
and unfortunately today is
This will be true if c_1 is
going to be really mathematical
and really no algorithms today,
which is sort of an anticlimax.
But next lecture we will talk
about real algorithms and will
apply all the things we learned
today to real algorithms.
This is big O-notation,
capital O-notation.
We have f(n)=O[g(n)].
This means that there are some
suitable constants,
c and n_o, such that f is
bounded by cg(n) for all
sufficiently large n.
So, this is pretty intuitive
notion.
We have seen it before.
We are going to assume that
f(n) is non-negative here.
And I just want f(n) to be
bounded above by g(n).
We have seen a bunch of
examples, but something like
2n^2=O(n^3) defined.
And roughly this means if you
drop leading constants and low
order terms then this is less
than or equal to that.
So, big O corresponds roughly
to less than or equal to.
But this is the formalization.
Another way to think of it
formally, a funny thing about
this notation is it is
asymmetric.
Normally, you think of
equality being symmetric.
If A=B then B=A.
But it's not true here.
We do not have n^3 being big O
of n^2.
We don't even have big O of n^3
equaling n^2.
So, we will see exactly what
that means in a second.
But before we get there,
this is a bit bizarre notation
and you should always think
about what it really means.
Another way to think about what
it really means is that f(n) is
in some set of functions that
are like g.
You could define big O[g(n)] to
be a set of functions,
let's call it f(n),
such that there exist
constants.
They are the same definition,
I think, fancy here,
c and n_o, such that we have
the bound f(n) is between zero
and cg(n).
It is a bit of a long
definition, and that is why we
use the notation,
to avoid having to write this
over and over.
You can think of instead of n^2
being equal to big O of n^3,
what we really mean is that
2n^2 is in the set big O(n^3).
When we write equal sign,
we in some sense mean this in
the set, but we are going to use
equal sign.
You could write this.
And occasionally you see papers
that write this,
but this is the notation that
we are going to use.
That has the consequence the
equal sign is asymmetric,
just like this operator.
We have some nifty ways that we
actually use big O-notation.
And it is using it as a macro.
By the way, we have a lot to
cover today, so I am going to go
relatively fast.
If anything is unclear,
just stop, ask questions,
then I will slow down.
Otherwise, I will take this as
all completely obvious and I can
keep going at full speed.
The convention,
this is intuitive,
I guess, if you do some macro
programming or something,
but it's a bit more
mathematical.
We have defined big O-notation
and it equals big O of
something.
And so we have only defined big
O when on the equal sign we have
big O of some function.
But it is useful to have some
general expression on the
right-hand side that involves
big O.
For example,
let's say we have f(n) = n^3 +
O(n^2).
This is attempting to get an
error bound.
This is saying f(n) is
basically n^3 but there are
these lower order terms that are
O(n^2).
And so this means that there is
a function, shorthand for a
function, h(n) which is in
O(n^2) or equals O(n^2) such
that f(n) = n^3 + h(n).
It is saying that there are
some lower order terms that are
bounded above by some constant
times n^2 for sufficiently large
n, and that is what is here.
And then f(n) equals,
now this is a true equality,
n^3 plus that error term.
This is very useful here.
Essentially,
I am expressing what the lead
constant is and then saying
well, there is other stuff and
it's all at most n^2.
Saying that f(n) therefore is
also order n^3,
but that is a bit weaker of a
statement.
This is a bit more refined.
We won't need to use this too
often, but it is useful.
Sometimes we will see,
like in last class we even had
a big O inside a summation.
So, you can use them all over
the place.
The point is they represent
some function in that set.
A bit less intuitive,
and this is more subtle,
is what it means to have big O
on the left-hand side.
It means the same thing,
but there is some convention
what equality means.
And this is why equal sign is
asymmetric.
You should read equals like
"is".
Is means that everything over
here is something over here.
So, there is an implicit for
all on the left-hand side and
there exists on the right-hand
side.
This is a true statement.
Anything that is n^2 + O(n) is
also O(n^2), but not the other
way around.
So, this is a bit asymmetric.
If you think about it,
this is pretty intuitive but it
is subtle so you should be
careful.
This says for any expansion of
the macro on the left-hand side,
which should be f(n),
there is an expansion of the
macro on the right-hand side
such that we get equality.
And what this allows you to do
is if you have a chain of equal
signs relations,
a chain of "is"s,
then the very first one is
equal to or bounded by the very
last one.
So, you can chain equal signs
the way you normally would.
You just cannot flip them
around.
Good.
So, that's big O-notation.
Any questions about that?
So, big O is great for
expressing upper bounds.
But we also want to talk about
lower bounds.
For algorithms,
we usually care about upper
bounds on their running time.
Running times at most n^2 is at
most n log n up to big O,
but sometimes we need to
express functions that are at
least some quantity.
For example,
we will show that sorting
requires at least n log n time
in some model.
So, we need some other notation
for that.
And the notation is big
Omega-notation.
And it is pretty symmetric.
I will just write out the set
definition here.
And we are going to write f(n)=
big Omega[g(n)] to mean f(n) is
at least some constant times
g(n) --
-- for sufficiently large n.
So, I am basically just
reversing the inequality
relation between f and g,
nothing surprising,
just to have it there.
A random example,
and now we will get a little
bit more sophisticated,
root n= big Omega(lg n).
And you should read this that
up to constant factors root n is
at least log n for sufficiently
large n.
So, omega sort of corresponds
to greater than or equal to.
Let me give you some analogies.
We have big O,
we have big omega,
this is less than or equal to,
this is greater than or equal
to.
And I am going to fill in some
more here in a moment.
It's nice to have all the usual
operators we have.
Normally we have strict less
than, strict greater than and
equal sign.
And we want those sort of
analogs in the asymptotic world
where we ignore constant factors
and ignore lower order terms.
We have, for example,
big Theta[g(n)].
This is a capital theta which
means you write the horizontal
bar in the middle as opposed to
all the way through.
I didn't invent Greek,
so that is the way it is.
Theta means that you are less
than or equal to and you are
greater than or equal to up to
constant factors,
so it is the inner section of
these two sets,
big O and big Omega.
That is sort of like equal sign
but, of course,
this is very different.
You have things like n^2 is big
Theta of 2(n^2) because you
ignore constant factors,
but all of these other
relations, OK,
n^2 + O(n) = Theta(n^2),
but this does not hold with
theta because square root of n
is really asymptotically bigger
than log n.
And some of the other examples
we saw like n^2 versus n^3,
those don't hold with T.
And we have some strict
notation which are the little
o-notation and little
omega-notation.
There is no little theta
because there is not notion of
strict equality versus unstrict
equality.
Little o is going to correspond
roughly to less than and little
omega is going to correspond to
greater than.
This is a notation you will
just have to get used to.
And I am not going to define it
precisely here because it is
almost exactly the same.
The difference is that instead
of saying there exists constant
c and n_o, you have to say for
every constant c there exists a
constant n_o.
The relationship between f and
g, this inequality must hold for
all c instead of just for 1.
And so n_o can now depend on c.
You can assume that really n is
sufficiently large,
but this gives you a strict
inequality.
No matter what constant you put
here, in front of g,
let's say we are doing little
o, f will be still less than c
times g for sufficiently large
n.
We have some random examples.
We are again ignoring
constants.
n^2 is always less than n^3 for
sufficiently large n.
And it is a bit subtle here.
I mean in order to prove
something like this,
it will become intuitive after
you manipulate it a little bit.
You have to figure out what n_o
is in terms of c.
I think it something like 2/c.
If we have less than or equal
to, that should be right.
As long n is at least this big,
no matter how small of a c,
you should think of c here as
being epsilon now,
in the usual epsilon and
deltas.
No matter how small c gets,
still I can bound n^2 in terms
of n^3, upper bound,
but whenever you have theta you
do not have either of these
relations.
For example,
Ωn^2 = Theta(n^2) and it is not
little o(n^2) and it not little
omega(n^2) because it is exactly
n^2.
You will get some sense in
order relation out of this,
although there are some messy
behaviors as you will see in
your problem set.
Any questions about asymptotic
notation?
That is the quick rundown.
Now we are going to use it to
solve some recurrences.
Although we won't use it that
much today, we will use it a lot
more on Wednesday.
OK.
We will move onto the second
topic of today,
which is solving recurrences.
You have probably solved some
recurrences before in 6.042 or
whatever discrete math class you
have taken.
We are going to do more and
have some techniques here that
are particularly useful for
analyzing recursive algorithms,
and we will see that mostly on
Wednesday.
There are three main methods
that we are going to use here
for solving recurrences.
The first one is the
substitution method.
There is no general procedure
for solving a recurrence.
There is no good algorithm for
solving recurrences,
unfortunately.
We just have a bunch of
techniques.
Some of them work some of the
time, and if you are lucky yours
will work for your recurrence,
but it is sort of like solving
an integral.
You have to just know some of
them, you have to know various
methods for solving them.
It is usually easy to check if
you have the right answer.
Just like with integrals,
you just differentiate and say
oh, I got the right answer.
And that is essentially the
idea of substitution method.
Substitution method will always
work, but unfortunately Step 1
is guess the answer.
And you have to guess it
correctly.
That makes it a big difficult.
You don't have to guess it
completely.
You can usually get away with
not knowing the constant
factors, which is a good thing
because we don't really care
about the constant factors.
You guess the form.
You say oh, it is going to be
roughly n^2, and so it's some
constant times n^2 presumably.
So, you guess that.
We are going to figure out the
constants.
You try to verify whether the
recurrence satisfies this bound
by induction,
and that is the key.
Substitution uses induction.
And from that you usually get
the constants for free.
You figure out what the
constants have to be in order to
make this work.
So, that is the general idea.
You will see a few examples of
this.
Actually, the same example
several times.
Unfortunately,
this is what you might call,
I don't know.
This is an algorithm,
but it uses an oracle which is
knowing the right answer.
But sometimes it is not too
hard to guess the answer.
It depends.
If you look at this recurrence,
T(n) = 4T(n/2) + n,
we should implicitly always
have some base case of T of some
constant, usually 1 is a
constant, so we don't really
care about the base case.
For algorithms that is always
the case.
And we want to solve this
thing.
Does anyone have a guess to
what the solution is?
Ideally someone who doesn't
already know how to solve this
recurrence.
OK.
How many people know how to
solve this recurrence?
A few, OK.
And, of the rest,
any guesses?
If you look at what is going on
here, here you have T(n/2) and
let's ignore this term more or
less.
We have n/2 here.
If we double n and get T(n)
then we multiply the value by 4.
And then there is this additive
end, but that doesn't matter so
much.
What function do you know that
when you double the argument the
output goes up by a factor of 4?
Sorry?
n^2,yeah.
You should think n^2 and you
would be right.
But we won't prove n^2 yet.
Let's prove something simpler,
because it turns out proving
that it is at most n^2 is a bit
of a pain.
We will see that in just a few
minutes.
But let's guess that T(n) =
O(n^3) first because that will
be easier to prove by induction.
You sort of see how it is done
in the easy case,
and then we will actually get
the right answer,
n^2, later.
I need to prove.
What I am going to do is guess
that T(n) is some constant times
n^3 at most, so I will be a
little more precise.
I cannot use the big O-notation
in the substitution method so I
have to expand it out to use
constants.
I will show you why in a little
bit, but let me just tell you at
a high level what is important
in not using big O-notation.
Big O-notation is great if you
have a finite chain of big O
relations, you know,
n^2 is big O(n^3) is big O(n^4)
is big O(n^4) is big O(n^4).
That is all true.
And so you get that n^2 is big
O(n^4).
But if you have an infinite
chain of those relations then
the first thing is not big O of
the last thing.
You have to be very careful.
For example,
this is a total aside on the
lecture notes.
Suppose you want to prove that
n = O(1).
This is a great relation.
If it were true,
every algorithm would have
constant running time.
This is not true.
Not in Wayne's World notation.
You could "prove this by
induction" by saying well,
base case is 1 = O(1).
OK, that is true.
And then the induction step as
well, if I know that n-1,
so let's suppose that n-1 =
O(1), well, that implies that n,
which is (n-1) +1,
if this is O(1) and 1 = O(1),
the whole thing is O(1).
And that is true.
If you knew that (n-1) = O(1)
and 1 = O(1) then their sum is
also O(1), but this is a false
proof.
You cannot induct over big Os.
What is going on here is that
the constants that are implicit
in here are changing.
Here you have some big O of 1,
here you have some big O of 1.
You are probably doubling the
constant in there every time you
do this relation.
If you have a finite number of
doubling of constants,
no big deal,
it is just a constant,
two the power number of
doublings.
But here you are doing n
doublings and that is no good.
The constant is now depending
on n.
So, we are avoiding this kind
of problem by writing out the
constant.
We have to make sure that
constant doesn't change.
Good.
Now I have written out the
constant.
I should be safe.
I am assuming it for all k less
than n, now I have to prove it
for k equal to n.
I am going to take T(n) and
just expand it.
I am going to do the obvious
thing.
I have this recurrence how to
expand T(n).
Then it involves T(n/2).
And I know some fact about
T(n/2) because n/2 is less than
n.
So, let's expand.
T(n) = 4T(n/2) + n.
And now I have an upper bound
on this thing from the induction
hypothesis.
This is at most 4 times c times
the argument cubed plus n.
Continuing on here.
Let's expand this a little bit.
We have n cubed over 2 cubed.
Two cubed is 8,
so 4 over 8 is a half.
So, we have Ωcn^3 + n.
And what I would like this to
be is, so at the bottom where I
would like to go is that this is
at most cn3.
That is what I would like to
prove to reestablish the
induction hypothesis for n.
What I will do,
in order to see when that is
case, is just write this as what
I want, so this is sort of the
desired value,
cn3, minus whatever I don't
want.
This is called the residual.
Now I have to actually figure
this out.
Let's see.
We have cn^3,
but only Ωcn^3 here,
so I need to subtract off Ωcn^3
to get that lead term correct.
And then I have plus n and
there is a minus here,
so it is minus n.
And that is the residual.
In order for this to be at most
this, I need that the residual
is non-negative.
This is if the residual part is
greater than or equal to zero,
which is pretty easy to do
because here I have control over
c.
I get to pick c to be whatever
I want.
And, as long as c is at least,
oh, I don't know,
2, then this is a 1 at least.
Then I have n^3 should be
greater than or equal to n.
And that is always the case.
For example,
this is true if c is at least
And I don't think it matters
what n is, but let's say n is at
least 1 just for kicks.
So, what we have done is proved
that T(n) is at most some
constant times n^3.
And the constant is like 1.
So, that is an upper bound.
It is not a tight upper bound.
We actually believed that it is
n^2, and it is,
but you have to be a little
careful.
This does not mean that the
answer is n^3.
It just means that at most n^3
is big O(n^3).
And this is a proof by
induction.
Now, technically I should have
put a base case in this
induction, so there is a little
bit missing.
The base case is pretty easy
because T(1) is some constant,
but it will sort of influence
things.
If the base case T(1) is some
constant.
And what we need is that it is
at most c times one cubed,
which is c.
And that will be true as long
as you choose c to be
sufficiently large.
So, this is true if c is chosen
Now, we don't care about
constants, but the point is just
to be a little bit careful.
It is not true that T(n) is at
most 1 times n^2,
even though here all we need is
that c is at least 1.
For the base case to work,
c actually might have to be a
hundred or whatever T(1) is.
So, be a little bit careful
there.
It doesn't really affect the
answer, usually it won't because
we have very simple base cases
here.
OK, so let's try to prove the
tight bound of O(n^2).
I am not going to prove an
omega bound, but you can prove
an omega n squared bound as well
using substitution method.
I will just be satisfied for
now proving an upper bound of n
squared.
Let's try to prove that T(n),
this is the same recurrence,
I want to prove that it is
O(n^2).
I am going to do the same
thing.
And I will write a bit faster
because this is basically
copying.
Except now, instead of three,
I have two.
Then I have T(n) = 4T(n/2) + n.
I expand this T(n/2).
This is at most 4c(n/2)^2 + n.
And now, instead of have 2
cubed, I have 2 squared,
which is only 4.
The fours cancel.
I get cn^2 + n.
And if you prefer to write it
as desired minus residual,
then I have cn^2 - (-n).
And I want this to be
non-negative.
And it is damn hard for minus n
to be non-negative.
If n is zero we are happy,
but unfortunately this is an
induction on n.
It's got to hold for all n
greater than or equal to 1.
This is not less than or equal
to cn^2.
Notice the temptation is to
write that this equals O(n^2),
which is true for this one
step.
cn^2 - (-n),
well, these are both order n,
or this is order n,
this is order n squared.
Certainly this thing is O(n^2),
that is true,
but it is not completing the
induction.
To complete the induction,
you have to prove the induction
hypothesis for n with this
constant c.
Here you are getting a constant
c of like c + 1,
which is not good.
This is true but useless.
It does not finish the
induction, so you can sort of
ignore that.
This proof doesn't work,
which is kind of annoying
because we feel,
in our heart of hearts,
that T(n) = n^2.
It turns out to fix this you
need to express T(n) in a
slightly different form.
This is, again,
divine inspiration.
And, if you have a good
connection to some divinity,
you are all set.
[LAUGHTER] But it is a little
bit harder for the rest of us
mere mortals.
It turns out,
and maybe you could guess this,
that the idea is we want to
strengthen the induction
hypothesis.
We assumed this relatively weak
thing, T(k) is less than or
equal to some constant times
k^2.
We didn't know what the
constant was,
that is fine,
but we assumed that there were
no lower order terms.
I want to look at lower order
terms.
Maybe they play a role.
And if you look at this
progression you say,
oh, well, I am getting
something like n^2 and the
constants are pretty damn tight.
I mean the fours are canceling
and the c just is preserved.
How am I going to get rid of
this lower order term plus n?
Well, maybe I could subtract
off a linear term in here and,
if I am lucky,
it will cancel with this one.
That is all the intuition we
have at this point.
It turns out it works.
We look at T(n) and this is
4T(n/2) + n as usual.
Now we expand a slightly
messier form.
We have 4[c_1*(n/2)^2 -
c_2*(n/2)] + n.
This part is the same because
the fours cancel again.
So, we get c_1*n^2,
which is good.
I mean that is sort of the form
we want.
Then we have something times n,
so let's figure it out.
We have a plus 1 times n,
so let's write it 1 minus c_2
over 2 times n.
Oops, got that wrong.
There is four times a two so,
in fact, the two is upstairs.
Let me double check.
Right.
OK.
Now we can write this as
desired minus residual.
And we have to be a little
careful here because now we have
a stronger induction hypothesis
to prove.
We don't just need it is at
most c_1*n^2,
which would be fine here
because we could choose c_2 to
be large, but what we really
need is c_1*n^2 - c_2*n,
and then minus some other
stuff.
This is, again,
desired minus residual.
And minus residual,
let's see, we have a minus 1
and we have a minus c_2.
That doesn't look so happy.
Plus c_2, thank you,
because that again looked
awfully negative.
It is plus c_2.
I am getting my signs,
there is a minus here and there
is one minus here,
so there we go.
Again, I want my residual to be
greater than or equal to zero.
And if I have that I will be
all set in making this inductive
argument.
Office hours start this week,
in case you are eager to go.
They are all held in some room
in Building 24,
which is roughly the midpoint
between here and Stata,
I think, for no particular
reason.
And you can look at the Web
page for details on the office
hours.
Continuing along,
when is c_2 - 1 going to be
greater than or equal to zero?
Well, that is true if c_2 is at
least 1, which is no big deal.
Again, we get to choose the
constants however we want.
It only has to hold for some
choice of constants.
So, we can set c_2 greater than
or equal to 1.
And then we are happy.
That means this whole thing is
less than or equal to c_1*n^2 -
c_2*n if c_2 is greater than or
equal to 1.
It is kind of funny here.
This finishes the induction,
at least the induction step.
We proved now that for any
value of c_1,
and provided c_2 is at least
one.
We have to be a little more
careful that c_1 does actually
have to be sufficiently large.
Any particular reason why?
c_1 better not be negative,
indeed.
c_1 has to be positive for this
to work, but it even has to be
larger than positive depending.
Sorry.
I have been going so fast,
I haven't asked you questions.
Now you are caught off guard.
Yeah?
Because of the base case,
exactly.
So, the base case will have
T(1) is c_1 time 1 squared minus
c_2, we want to prove that it is
at most this,
and T(1) is some constant we
have assumed.
We need to choose c_1 to be
sufficiently larger than c_2,
in fact, so c_2 has to be at
least 1.
c_1 may have to be at least a
hundred more than one if this is
sufficiently large.
And sufficiently large now
means with respect to c_2.
You have to be a little bit
careful, but in this case it
doesn't matter.
Any questions about the
substitution method?
That was the same example three
times.
In the end, it turned out we
got the right answer.
But we sort of had to know the
answer in order to find it,
which is a bit of a pain.
It would certainly be nicer to
just figure out the answer by
some procedure,
and that will be the next two
techniques we talk about.
Sorry?
How would you prove a lower
bound?
I haven't tried it for this
recurrence, but you should be
able to do exactly the same
form.
Argue that T(n) is greater than
or equal to c_1*n^2 - c_2*n.
I didn't check whether that
particular form will work,
but I think it does.
Try it.
These other methods will give
you, in some sense,
upper and lower bounds if you
are a little bit careful.
But, to really check things,
you pretty much have to do the
substitution method.
And you will get some practice
with that.
Usually we only care about
upper bounds.
Proving upper bounds like this
is what we will focus on,
but occasionally we need lower
bounds.
It is always nice to know that
you have the right answer by
proving a matching lower bound.
The next method we will talk
about is the recursion-tree
method.
And it is a particular way of
adding up a recurrence,
and it is my favorite way.
It usually just works.
That's the great thing about
it.
It provides you intuition for
free.
It tells you what the answer is
pretty much.
It is slightly nonrigorous,
this is a bit of a pain,
so you have to be really
careful when you apply it.
Otherwise, you might get the
wrong answer.
Because it involves dot,
dot, dots, our favorite three
characters, but dot,
dot, dots are always a little
bit nonrigorous so be careful.
Technically,
what you should do is find out
what the answer is with
recursion-tree method.
Then prove that it is actually
right with the substitution
method.
Usually that is not necessary,
but you should at least have in
your mind that that is required
rigorously.
And probably the first few
recurrences you solve,
you should do it that way.
When you really understand the
recursion-tree method,
you can be a little bit more
sloppy if you are really sure
you have the right answer.
Let's do an example.
We saw recursion trees very
briefly last time with mergesort
as the intuition why it was n
log n.
And, if you took an example
like the one we just did with
the recursion-tree method,
it is dead simple.
Just to make our life harder,
let's do a more complicated
recursion.
Here we imagine we have some
algorithm.
It starts with a problem size
n, it recursively solves a
problem of size n/4,
it then recursively solves a
problem of size n/2,
and it does n^2 work on the
side without nonrecursive work.
What is that?
I mean that is a bit less
obvious, I would say.
What we are going to do is draw
a picture, and we are just going
to expand out that recursion in
tree form --
-- and then just add everything
up.
We want the general picture,
and the general principle in
the recursion-tree method is we
just draw this as a picture.
We say well,
T(n) equals the sum of n^2,
T(n/4) and T(n/2).
This is a weird way of writing
a sum but why not write it that
way.
This is going to be a tree.
And it is going to be a tree by
recursively expanding each of
these two leaves.
I start by expanding T(n) to
this, then I keep expanding,
expanding, expanding
everything.
Let's go one more step.
We have this n^2,
T(n/4), T(n/2).
If we expand one more time,
this is going to be n^2 plus
two things.
The first thing is going to be
(n/4)^2, the second thing is
going to be (n/2)^2.
Plus their recursive branches.
We have T(n/16) and T(n/8).
Here my arithmetic shows thin.
This better be the same,
T(n/8), and this should be
T(n/4), I believe.
You just keep going forever,
I mean, until you get down to
the base case where T is a
constant.
So, I am now going to skip some
steps and say dot,
dot, dot.
This is where you have to be
careful.
We have n^2,
(n/4)^2, (n/2)^2.
Now this is easy because I have
already done them all.
(n/16)^2, (n/8)^2,
(n/8)^2 again,
(n/4)^2 and et cetera,
dot, dot, dot,
of various levels of recursion
here.
At the bottom,
we are going to get a bunch of
constants.
These are the leaves.
I would like to know how many
leaves there are.
One challenge is how many
leaves in this tree could there
be?
This is a bit subtle,
unlike mergesort or unlike the
previous recurrence we solved,
the number of leaves here is a
bit funny because we are
recursing at different speeds.
This tree is going to be much
smaller than this tree.
It is going to have smaller
depth because it has already
done down to (n/16).
Here it has only gone down to
(n/4).
But how many leaves are there
in this recursion tree?
All I need is an upper bound,
some reasonable upper bound.
I can tell you it is at most
T(n^10), but that is a bit
unreasonable.
It should be less than n,
good.
Why is it less than n?
Exactly.
I start with a problem of size
n.
And I recurse into a problem
that n/4 and a problem that says
n/2.
When I get down to one I stop.
So, n/4 + n/2 = æn,
which is strictly less than n.
So, definitely the total number
of leaves has to be at most n.
If I start out with n sort of
stuff and get rid of a quarter
of it and then recurse,
it is definitely going to be
less than n stuff at the bottom.
So, strictly less than n
leaves.
At this point,
I have done nothing
interesting.
And then the second cool idea
in recursion trees is you don't
just expand this tree and see
what it looks like and then say,
well, God, how the hell am I
going to sum that?
You sum it level by level.
That is the only other idea.
It usually works really,
really well.
Here it is a bit complicated
and I have to think a bit to
figure out n^2 is n^2.
That is the first level.
Easy.
The second level,
I have to think a lot harder.
There are three kinds of
mathematicians,
those who can add and those who
cannot, and I am the latter kind
so I need your help.
Can you add these things
together?
It's n^2 over something.
Please?
(5/16)n^2.
Now I really need your help.
I think that one I could have
done, but this one is a little
bit harder.
I will go look at my notes
while you compute that.
Any answers?
73/256.
Anyone else confirm that?
It seems a bit high to me.
73 does not sound right to me.
64?
Closer.
It is actually important that
we get this right.
The 256 is correct.
I can tell.
Everyone should know that 16^2
= 256.
We are computer scientists.
25, good.
We have two people saying 25,
therefore it is correct by
democracy.
[LAUGHTER] 25 is also what my
notes say, and I computed it at
home.
(25/256)n^2 is the right
answer.
Now, did anyone notice
something magical about this
progression?
It squares each time,
good.
And, if we were going to add
these up, you might call it?
A geometric series,
very good.
So, it turns out this is
geometric.
And we know how to sum
geometric series,
at least you should.
We started n^2.
We know that at the bottom,
well, this is not quite a
level, we get something like n,
but we are decreasing
geometrically.
So, the total,
I mean the solution to the
recurrence is the sum of all the
numbers in this tree.
If we added it up level by
level and then add up all the
levels that is going to give us
the answer.
This is the total computed
level by level.
It is just a cute way to
compute it.
It usually gives you nice
answers like geometric answers.
We have n^2(1 + 5/16 + 25/256 +
...).
And, if we believe in fate and
we see this three number
recurrence, we know that we have
the right answer.
In general, it is going to be
(5/16)k, at least we hope,
and so on.
And it keeps going.
It doesn't go on infinitely,
but let's just assume it goes
on infinitely.
That will be an upper bound
that goes on forever.
This is all times n^2.
Now, if you are going to know
one thing about geometric
series, you should know that 1 +
Ω + º, if you sum all the powers
of 2 you get 2.
We are computer scientists.
We have got to know at least
the binary case.
This is like writing 0.1111111
in binary, actually,
And 11111 forever is the same
as 1, so this is 2.
This is even smaller.
We have 5/16,
that is less than a half and
then we are squaring each time,
so this is even less than 2.
If you want,
there is a nifty formula for
solving the general geometric
series, but all we need is that
it is a constant.
This is O(n^2).
It is also O(n^2).
It is pretty obvious that it is
O(n^2) because the top thing is
n^2.
So, there is our lower bound of
And we have it within a factor
of 2, which is pretty good.
You actually get a better
factor here.
So, that is recursion-tree
method.
It is a little shaky here
because we have these dot,
dot, dots, and we just believe
that it is geometric.
It turns out most of the time
it is geometric.
No problem here.
I would definitely check it
with the substitution method
because this is not obvious to
me that it is going to be
geometric.
In the cases we will look at in
a moment, it will be much
clearer, so clear that we can
state a theorem that everything
is working fine.
And still time,
good.
So, that was recursion-trees.
There is one more method we are
going to talk about,
and you could essentially think
of it as an application of the
recursion-tree method but it is
made more precise.
And it is an actual theorem,
whereas recursion trees,
if the dot, dot,
dots aren't obvious,
you better check them.
The sad part about the master
method is it is pretty
restrictive.
It only applies to a particular
family of recurrences.
It should be T(n) = aT(n/b) +
f(n).
Am I going to call it f?
Yes, I will call it f.
In particular,
it will not cover the
recurrence I just solved because
I was recursing on two different
problems of different sizes.
Here, every problem you recurse
on should be of the same size.
There are a subproblems.
A way to think of this is a
recursive algorithm.
You have a subproblems.
Each of them is of size n/b,
so the total costs will be
this.
Then you are doing f(n)
nonrecursive work.
A few constraints.
a should be at least 1,
should have at least 1
recursion.
b should be strictly greater
than 1.
You better make the problem
smaller or else it is going to
be infinity.
And f should have some nice
property.
f(n) should be asymptotically
positive.
How many people know what
asymptotically positive means?
No one.
OK, you haven't read the
textbook.
That's OK.
I haven't read it either,
although don't tell Charles.
And he'd notice.
And what might you think
asymptotically positive means?
That we can do a little bit
better.
Sorry?
Yes, it means for large enough
n, f(n) is positive.
This means f(n) is greater than
zero for n, at least some n_o,
so for some constant n_o.
Eventually it should be
positive.
I mean, we don't care about
whether it's negative 1 for n=1,
not a big deal.
It won't affect the answer
because we only care about the
asympotics within.
The master method,
you gave it a recurrence of
this form, it tells you the
answer.
That is the great thing about
the master method.
The annoying thing about the
master method is that it has
three cases.
It is a big long.
It takes a little bit longer to
memorize than all the others
because the others are just
ideas.
Here we need to actually
remember a few things.
Let me state the theorem.
Well, not quite yet.
There is one very simple idea,
which is we are going to
compare this nonrecursive work
f(n) with a very particular
function n^(log_b(a)).
Why n^(log_b(a))?
You will see later.
It turns out it is the number
of leaves in the recursion tree,
but that is foreshadowing.
So, it is either less,
equal or bigger.
And here we care about
asymptotics.
And we have to be a little bit
more precious about less,
equal or bigger.
You might think well,
it means little o,
big Theta, or little omega.
It would be nice if the theorem
held for all of those cases,
but it leaves some gaps.
Let's start with Case 1.
Case 1 is when f is smaller.
And not just that it is little
o, but it is actually quite a
bit smaller.
It has got to be polynomially
smaller than n^(log_b(a)).
For some positive epsilon,
the running time should be this
n to this constant log base b of
a minus that epsilon,
so it is really polynomially
smaller than n^(log_b(a)).
We cannot handle the little o
case, that's a little bit too
strong.
This is saying it is really
quite a bit smaller.
But the answer then is really
simple, T(n) =
Theta(n^(log_b(a))).
Great.
That is Case 1.
Case 2 is when f(n) is pretty
much equal to n^(log_b(a)).
And by pretty much equal I mean
up to poly log factors.
This is log base 2 of n to the
power k.
You should know this notation.
For example,
k could be zero.
And then they are equal up to
constant factors,
for some k greater than or
equal to zero.
Less than will not work,
so it is really important that
k is non-negative.
It should probably be an
integer.
It doesn't actually matter
whether there is an integer,
but there it is.
It could n^(log_b(a)) times log
n or just times nothing,
whatever.
Again, the solution is easy
here, T(n) = Theta(n^(log_b(a))*
lg^(k+1)(n)).
Presumably it has to be at
least times log k.
It turns out it is log to the k
plus 1 of n.
That is Case 2.
We have one more case which is
slightly more complicated.
We need to assume slightly more
for Case 3.
But Case 3 is roughly when f(n)
grows bigger than n^(log_b(a)).
So, it should be capital Omega,
here is one place where we get
to use omega,
(n^(log_b(a)) + epsilon) for
some positive epsilon.
It should grow not just bigger
but polynomially bigger.
Here it was growing just a log
factor bigger,
poly log, and here it is a
polynomial factor.
In this case,
we need another assumption
about f because we worry a
little bit about how quickly f
grows.
We want to make sure that as
you go down the recursion f gets
smaller.
It would be kind of nice if f
gets smaller as you go down,
otherwise you are,
again, trying to sum to
infinity or whatever.
I see why this is for some
epsilon prime greater than zero.
What I would like is that if I
just sort of take the
recurrence, this T(n) and just
throw in fs instead,
f(n) should be somehow related
to af(n/b).
What I would like is that f(n),
which is at the top of the
recursion tree,
should be bigger than the thing
at the next level down.
The sum of all the values at
the next level down should be
bigger by some constant factor.
Here I have the next level down
is at most some 1 - e,
something strictly less than 1,
some constant strictly less
than 1 times the thing at the
top level.
I need that to make sure things
are getting smaller as I go
down.
Then T(n) = Theta[f(n)].
And that is the theorem.
This is the master theorem or
whatever you want to call it.
It is not named after some guy
name Master.
It is just the master of all
methods because it is very easy
to apply.
Let's apply it a few times.
It is a bit much to take in all
at once.
And then I will give you a
sketch of the proof to see that
it is really not that surprising
this is true if you look at the
recursion-tree.
But first let's just try using
it.
For example,
we could take T(n) = 4T(n/2) +
n.
This is a, this is b,
this is f(n).
The first thing we should
compute is n^(log_b(a)).
This I think even I can do.
Log base 2 of 4.
Yeah, log base 2 I can do.
This is n^2.
OK, so is f(n) smaller or
bigger than n^2?
Well, f(n) = n.
n^2 is clearly bigger by a
polynomial factor.
So, we are in Case 1.
What is the answer?
n^2, yeah.
It is T(n^(log_b(a))),
which here it is just n^2.
Let's do some slight variation.
I am going to keep a and b the
same and just change f.
Let's say T(n) = 4T(n/2) + n^2.
This is like drill spelling.
n^2 is asymptotically the same
as n^2 even up to constants.
What is the answer?
This is Case 2.
It is slightly harder.
What is k in this example? Zero.
The answer is?
Survey says?
n^2 log n.
Good.
And a couple more.
T(n) = 4T(n/2) + n^3.
What is the answer?
n^3.
This is Case 3.
I know this is pretty boring.
At this point we are just
applying this stupid theorem.
How about n^2/lg n?
What is the answer?
Good.
In this case no one should
answer.
It is a big tricky.
I forget exactly the answer.
I think it is like n^2 log log
n over log n,
no?
Oh, no.
n^2 log log n,
that's right.
Yeah.
But you shouldn't know that,
and this doesn't follow from
the master method.
This is something you would
have to solve,
probably with the
recursion-tree would be a good
way to do this one,
and you need to know some
properties of logs to know how
that goes.
But here the master method does
not apply.
And so you have to use a
different method.
OK.
The last thing I want to do is
tell you why the master method
is true, and that makes it much
more intuitive,
especially using
recursion-trees,
why everything works.
This is a sketch of a proof,
not the full thing.
You should read the proof in
the textbook.
It is not that much harder than
what I will show,
but it is good for you to know
the formal details.
I don't have time here to do
all of the details.
I will just tell you the
salient parts.
This is the proof sketch or the
intuition behind the master
method.
What we are going to do is just
take the recursion-tree for this
recurrence and add up each level
and then add up all the levels
and see what we get.
We start with f(n) at the top
after we have expanded one
level.
Then we get a different
problems, each of n/b.
And after we expand them it
will f(n/b) for each one.
They are all the same size.
Then we expand all of those and
so on, and we get another a
subproblems from there.
We are going to get like
f((n/b)^2).
That is sort of decreasing
geometrically the size,
and so on and so on and so on,
until at the bottom we get
constant size problems.
This is a bit special because
this is the base case,
but we have some other constant
at the bottom.
We would like to know how many
leaves there are,
but that is a little bit tricky
at the moment.
Let's first compute the height
of this tree.
Let me draw it over here.
What is the height of this
tree?
I start with a problem of size
n.
I want to get down to a problem
of size 1.
How long does that take?
How many levels?
This is probably too easy for
some and not at your fingertips
for others.
Log base b of n,
good.
The height of this tree is
n^(log_b(a)),
because it is just how many
times I divide by b until I get
down to 1.
That is great.
Now I should be able to compute
the number of leaves because I
have branching factor a,
I have height h.
The number of leaves is a^h,
a^log_b(n).
Let me expand that a little
bit.
a^log_b(n), properties of logs,
we can take the n downstairs
and put the a upstairs,
and we get n^(log_b(a)).
Our good friend n^(log_b(a)).
So, that is why Our good friend
n^(log_b(a)) is so important in
the master method.
What we are doing is comparing
f, which is the top level,
to n^(log_b(a)),
which up to theta is the bottom
level.
Now the leaves are all at the
same level because we are
decreasing at the same rate in
every branch.
If I add up the cost at the
bottom level,
it is Theta(n^(log_b(a))).
I add up the things at the top
level it is f(n),
not terribly exciting.
But the next level,
this is a little bit more
interesting, is af(n/b),
which should look familiar if
you had the master method
already memorized,
it is that.
So, we know that af(n/b) has
decreased by some constant
factor, 1-epsilon prime.
We have gone down.
This is a constant factor
smaller than this.
And then you sum up the next
level.
It is going to be like
a^2f(n/b^2).
I see that I actually wrote
this wrong, the parentheses.
Sorry about that.
It is not (n/b)^2.
It is (n/b^2).
So, this sequence,
in Case 3 at least,
is decreasing geometrically.
If it is decreasing
geometrically up to constant
factors, it is dominated by the
biggest term,
which is f(n).
Therefore, in Case 3,
we get Theta[f(n)].
Let's look at the other cases,
and let me adapt those cases to
how much time we have left.
Wow, lot's of time.
Five minutes.
Tons of time.
What to do?
Let me write that down.
Case 3, the costs decrease.
Now, this is a place I would
argue where the dot,
dot, dot is pretty obvious.
Here, this is damn simple,
it is a^kf(n/b^k).
And, in Case 3,
we assume that the costs
decrease geometrically as we go
down the tree.
That was sort of backwards to
start with Case 3.
Let's do Case 1,
which is sort of the other
intuitively easy case.
In Case 1, we know that f(n) is
polynomially smaller than this
thing.
And we are sort of changing by
this very simple procedure in
the middle.
I am going to wave my hands if
this is where you need a more
formal argument.
I claim that this will increase
geometrically.
It has to increase
geometrically because this f(n)
is polynomially smaller than
this one, you are going to get
various polynomials in the
middle which interpret
geometrically from the small one
to the big one.
Therefore, the big one
dominates because it is,
again, geometric series.
As I said, this is intuition,
not a formal argument.
This one was pretty formal
because we assumed it,
but here you need a bit more
argument.
They may not increase
geometrically but they could
increase faster,
and that is also fine.
So, in Case 3,
you are dominated,
I mean you are always dominated
by the biggest term in a
geometric series.
Here it happens to be f(n) and
here you are dominated by
n^(log_b(a)) with a bottom term,
oh, Theta.
Case 2, here it is pretty easy
but you need to know some
properties of logs.
In Case 2, we assume that all
of these are basically the same.
I mean, we assume that the top
is equal to the bottom.
And this is changing in this
very procedural way.
Therefore, all of the ones in
the middle have to be pretty
much the same.
Not quite because here we don't
have the log factor.
Here we have a log to the k.
We have n^(log_b(a)) times log
to the kn.
Here we don't have the log to
the k.
So, the logs do disappear here.
It turns out the way they
disappear is pretty slowly.
If you look at the top half of
these terms, they will all have
log to the k.
The bottom half they will start
to disappear.
I am giving you some oracle
information.
If you take logs and you don't
change the argument by too much,
the logs remain.
Maybe halfway is too far.
The claim is that each level is
roughly the same,
especially the upper most
levels are all asymptotically
equal.
Roughly the same.
And, therefore,
the cost is one level,
here like f(n) times the number
of levels, h.
And h is log base b of n.
B is a constant so we don't
care.
This is Theta(lg n).
And, therefore,
we get T(n) = (n^(log_b(a))
lg^(k+1)(n)) times another log
n.
So, we get [f(n)lg n].
That is the very quick sketch.
Sorry, I am being pretty fuzzy
on Cases 1 and 2.
Read the proof because you will
have to, at some point,
manipulate logs in that way.
And that is all.
Any questions?
Or, you are all eager to go.
OK.
Thanks.
See you Wednesday.